ね中は後藤ローソン pain 肇社長リストだけちょっと色々とありましてですね何
か僕で最近ふと思ったんですけどもはいと時代めっちゃ楽しかったなと思いまして本会
なんとローソンでちょっと店長から戦隊なって話をしていたら
エジち店長することになりましたみてください名札店長の枝ですよろしくお願いします
それであの朝に今日言ったんですけども静岡のを見ててちょっと1日店長をさせて
いただくんですけどもうフックなんといってもローソンでそこそこ働いてた本なんだよ
ね結構使えるんですよ使えるんでちょっともし肇社長がローソンで働いたどうなるのか
ちょっとやってみたいと思います僕の得た時代とだいぶ変わっててなんか
レジとか色々システムが変わっててちょっと僕今働きだぞ多分足手まといになるので
ちょっと研修をしてからすでにコンビニで働いていきたいと思いますで発酵が
いらっしゃいます
某山代々をやばい理由完全に変わるぞ
ではそれ昔のこっち側米自動次いで納期な
線をお願いしますバイバイ夏が正780良いとお菓子でございます
ありがとうございました
ありがとうございますありがとうございます貼り付けて研修終わりましたもうバッチリ
です
今二代目プリペいいですねバーコードから電子マネーが多いので僕の時代にそんなのが
無かった時代が変わっているまぁそこにいかに僕は純銅して働けるが今回のポイントだ
と思いますそして阿野全成するにあたってちょっとひとつ目標を作りますカラー下君
全力で打ってみようと思います私の実力を生かしてカップせない方
の金具の売り上げを出せたらいいなと思うんでちょっと花布の売り上げの被災曲に挑戦
してみようと思いますわぁお店行ってきますよ
ああああああ
一応けど店に着いたんですけども
うん
待っていきましょうというわけで順次店長スタッフデーだ0
re ターゲットめっちゃ地を置いてあるんでをご覧下さい
ん
wh
ちょっと頑張ってからいいのかライガーが揚げたてを準備しておりますいかがでしょう
か
me
[音楽]
pjo
uh
mar
me
209税のがとうございます
ame
ございましたありがとうございますありがとうございます
[音楽]
barena
rar 可愛い軍隊 nd 母でしょうかー
だったとちょっと出て誠実凍結てきましたん
屋さんでから水訴えようぜ
ani
rar
anand スターダメージできつかったす普通に売ってた w
ああああああ
jr 腐敗
色ありました
レギュラーありました
レギュラーあり正社員レギュラーありましたレギュラー入りました
糸ありました
ベン嫌いじゃ
あげくんめっちゃ愛おしいなぁ
rar
[音楽]
ran 安定剤ましたーーー実際ありました
ハゲ軍がございましたプリキュアなりました
タイガーねがーまいりましたーーー
car
me
wh
インターネットれています財源チーズ&レッドゾーン入りましたーーー
ni
あれなんとなんだタイガー
者やありましたーーー
[音楽]
ブーブー rarejob
ああああああ
re j
lean on me
rar
やばいキッチビっすかねえ地下で220個からお気がありました
お線香を超えれば世界記録ですよねー w 味千個目指して頑張ります
ただ下を受けてメリックが出ちゃったーーーー
[拍手]
ああああああああ
会えばいいかなねっ韓国以上ぶりだよ
[音楽]
あなたは彼じゃねぇ
見えたァァァァ
カラーいやーあげなきゃ準備しておりまーでいかがでしょうなぁ
すごいです
car
ana ああああ
8さあ作業ですチーズは4つですよ
ああ
mar
ran
[音楽]
20ありがとうございまーありがとうございます思いまー
me
的なとチークこれ r 0じゃあ
チーズ大空いらっしゃい
ああああああ
だしていただけるのでしょうか女性 ba
[音楽]
まぁちょっと2時間経ちました後1時間です
頑張ります
car
wh
ni
いつかんがぁよりご応募ください
皆様からあげくんがぁ
登りますがというわけではありませんがまだありますぜひ開けたてのカラーリング食べ
ていってください
wh
meji
ああああああ
[音楽]
今でも750が揺れてて今のページだとうなきゃいけば多分世界記録いてるらしいんだ
よちょっと売り込みに行きます
皆さんはクライマー
土産がもうすぐ世界今日日いそうですよ世界なら止めでからあげ
使ってくださーーーーん
[拍手]
rar
みんな待ってる aime
いかがでしょうかああ
rar
限り rar
nan
rar
ああああああ
ええええええ
[音楽]
dj
me
[音楽]
ana ああああああああああ
ran じゃねぇマグなっちゃったーーーー
ダイナー3なぁネットにご員とか言ってみてくださいこれ
スター
me
ついに間に合わだけ買っちゃうよさ
見えまあだけのがリーカー問わず飾っておりマートマの軍用へ組んだまだ音ではー
wh
re re
[音楽]
2つの子のお客様も8人となりました
ああああああああ
ありがとうございまーさー
はいはーい
c レイヤー
あああああございましたーーーん
5分
という間ローソンに足を運んで頂きました皆様本当にもありがとうございました
1日10つを無事終了いたしましたはいというギアのすぎ久しぶりに接客業をやらせて
いたらいいなんですけれども
ップ普段土木たもちょっと態度変わりますね差別にローソンで働いてみてすごいあの
楽しかったしあの僕時代ちょっと人とお話
ちょっと苦手なんでああいう rain さんとお客様の関係で話せるって言うのが
なんかすごい僕は楽しかったですめっちゃ楽しかったしさんもとてもたくさんの方にお
越し頂いて本当に楽しかったですありがとうございましてできな鷹投具の販売数は
[音楽]
1223こでございました
ん
[音楽]
ほとんど僕の山中が出来ましたこれが県内販売の実績によりますと
えっと無事
にほんいちでしたてか1かん
ローソンで世界にあるのかな
世界一でしたうーん
ゼニーは1,000円 q ショップでしたねこれ1日使ってなんですよ僕3時間しか
働いてませんからっていう店内のみ販売の歴代最高売上という理由だったらしいです
しゃー
本強打しば世界一
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ